good morning believe nation today's
message is think for yourself over to
you Carl Icahn when you go out into the
world you should try to stand up against
the trend even though it's my enemy I
mean literally it might cost your job in
my question promotion but in the end
think for yourself be innovative try me
I'm not telling you go in and tell them
what to do you've got to be careful
about that obviously but but if you have
ideas go slam the table don't worry
about it come up with your own
imagination too because that's what this
country need I think this is one of the
hallmarks of true entrepreneurs of
people have had massive success is they
think for themselves they don't just
abide by the rules they often hate rules
you know they understand rules are there
for a reason but they're always
questioning the rules they're always
asking why do we do things that way and
in business it's not a good enough
answer to say because that's the way
we've always done things and for the
entrepreneurs who are out there
challenging the status quo those are the
ones who are gonna have the bigger
success if you are just doing something
the same way everybody else is doing in
your industry if you're selling the same
product at the same price with the same
service there's nothing unique you're
special different about you then you're
gonna have less than mediocre results
because those people been around longer
and have brand name have recognition a
client list for you to stand out you
have to be different you have to think
for yourself you have to find the thing
that you're upset about that there's a
problem that hasn't been solved and you
want to bring that to the market I did
the top ten rules for success because I
wanted to learn from all these
successful people and I was upset that I
had to watch hours and hours and hours
and hours of footage to get a couple of
Nuggets for me to digest
I created the entresto series because I
wanted a morning shot I wanted some
energy some ideas something quick in the
morning to get my day started I created
that out of my own necessity my own pain
and thankfully you guys have enjoyed and
join me on the process as well that's
how it starts right you have to think
for yourself and find a way to do
something differently I have a new
instructor that we're training at
Toronto dance
Elsa and she lives this right she hates
rules she's questioning everything and I
love it right I love it because again
this is the way we've always done it is
not a good enough answer and she'll come
to me and she'd say why do we do things
like this why did why does TDs do it
like this and that I don't have a good
answer with a logical reason as to why
we do it then maybe it's time to change
something so explaining it and saying
hey I'm open to feedback what do you
think how do we make it better right you
want to hire people too who want to
challenge the rules who want to do
something bigger who helped your company
build and grow and not just do things
the way you've done it because that's
how you've always done it so it's so so
so so so so important that you think for
yourself and believe in your ideas as
well so the question of the day today is
we're talking about breaking rules or
being upset with rules I'm curious what
rule what rule bothers you the most what
rule a business rule a life rule what
rule bothers you the most that needs to
be changed let's bring some change about
leave it down the comments below I'm
gonna join in the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
have an amazing day I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
you